Every time I babysit I wonder what the baby
is thinking.
And when it cries, I’m like what what small
human?
What are you trying to tell me?
The meaning of life?
And stop calling me peasant.
Hey guys Julia here for DNews
Babies.
Man, babies.
Cute.
Cooing.
Pooping little humans.
While adorable, they aren’t the smartest
in the bunch.
I mean, I hide behind my hands and they think
I’m gone forever.
And peek a boo!
My face just pops out of nowhere.
But lately researchers are finding out babies
are smarter than we think.
A recent study published in the journal Developmental
Science found that babies can reason logically,
even before the age of one.
Which apparently researchers thought people
couldn’t do until the age of 5 or 6.
How did researchers figure this out you ask?
Well it’s not like they could just give
babies a logic problem to solve.
Instead they had them watch puppets.
In this study the puppets acted out a little
scene of social hierarchy.
Basically puppet one is more dominant than
puppet two, then in another scene puppet two
is more dominant that puppet 3.
So who would be more dominant?
Puppet one or puppet three?
If you said puppet 1, congratulations! you’re
just as smart as a ten month old baby.
You can understand transitive inference, which
is a type of deductive reasoning which allows
someone to make inferences about things that
weren’t explicitly compared before.
Basically the researchers could tell what
a baby understood based on how long they stared
at the puppet show.
If the show went against the transitive inference
and puppet 3 was more dominant, then the babies
were confused and stared longer.
That’s based on earlier research that shows
that when something is unfamiliar or unexpected,
babies will look at it longer.
And it seems it’s not the only thing young
infants can grasp.
Knowledge of social situations seems to get
wired in pretty early on in brain development.
In a study published in the Journal of Experimental
Psychology: General researchers found that
infants as young as 9 months could understand
that people were likely to be friends based
on their shared interests; for example, if
they have the same reactions to food.
In this study researchers show babies videos
where people ate food.
They either really liked it or made a "hmph"
kind of gesture about it.
The babies expected those who liked the same
food to be friends and were confused when
they weren’t.
The researchers take this to mean that babies
are very aware of what’s going on around
them and keep track of people’s interactions.
Babies even have a kind of theory of mind
around 18 months according to a study published
in Developmental Psychology.
Which researchers thought kids couldn’t
do until age 8 or so.
Theory of Mind is trying to imagine what’s
going on in someone else’s head.
That someone else may want things different
from what you want.
In one clever experiment a researcher gave
babies two bowls.
One filled with broccoli and the other with
tasty crackers.
The babies prefered the crackers.
Then the researcher would eat from one of
the bowls and either make a happy or disgusted
reaction.
They gave the bowls back to the baby and asked
“can I have some”, if the researcher acted
happy about the broccoli, the baby gave them
broccoli, even though that’s not what the
babies prefered.
This showed that these young children could
understand someone else’s desires and use
that information in how they responded to
them.
Heck even adults struggle with this sometimes.
So babies are capable of logical reasoning
and empathy, something researchers thought
wasn’t possible.
So one of the lead researchers of the broccoli-goldfish
study Dr. Alison Gopnick believes adults could
learn a thing or two from babies.
You know how I said babies stare at things
that are new or confusing?
Well babies are really good at paying attention
to lots of new and novel things, they just
kind of soak in everything.
While as we grow up we learn to focus on just
one thing.
And sometimes that can blind us to other possibilities.
She said in an op-ed in the Wall Street Journal
that “Babies, on the other hand, seem to
have a positive hunger for the unexpected.”
And that means they’re like little ideal
scientists.
Yeah now I’m kind of terrified to baby sit
again.
I might not be so terrified of babies if I
knew exactly what I was getting into.
I mean what if you could control every detail
about your baby will turn out?
Sounds like science fiction?
Well designer babies might not be too far
off.
To learn more check out this video where julian
and i debate the pros and cons of designing
your baby.